so now we can come to the central topic
of our lecture which describes the
conditions under which a Markov chain
which is steady state the question that
we are asking and which we motivated in
the previous lecture by looking at an
example with a simple to state Markov
chain is the following we are asking
whether the probability of being in
state J at time n given that you started
at time zero instead I converge to some
constant PI of J in fact that question
consists of two part
do we have convergence and is it
independent of I we have seen example
where it is not always the case for
example in this Markov chain you have
two recurrent classes this is one
recurrent class here and then there is a
second recurrent class here and we know
that if we are interested in a long-term
priority of being in that state assuming
that you started in one of these states
here the priority will be 0 to be here
but if you started in one of these two
states the priority will be positive so
clearly here the initial conditions will
matter whenever you have two or more
recurrent classes so what would happen
if you have only one recurrent class so
let's let's remove this one and consider
this situation here where you have only
one recurrent class in that case what we
have seen this is still not sufficient
indeed if you look at this recurrent
class and the you are interested in nine
and assume that you studied at nine then
at time one who you will be either here
or here and at time two you will be back
at nine for sure and in general for time
and even the priority will be one and
for time and odd it will be zero so that
specific n step transition probability
in that situation here will never
converge it will keep oscillating
between zero and one so the issue here
is that we had a periodic recurrent
class and the period in that case was
two so let us consider now the final
case where you have only one recurrent
class
and that recurring class is not periodic
and how do we realize that this is not
periodic here well we have a self
transition here so now that we have one
recurrent class and this recurrent class
is a periodic the question is do you
have this kind of convergence here and
it turns out and this is the big theory
of Markov chains under the name of
steady-state convergence theorem that
indeed yes
the rij is do converge to a steady state
limit which we call a steady state
probability as long as these two
conditions are satisfied
so in summary not only these two
conditions are necessary like we had
seen without control example but they
are sufficient we are not going to prove
this theorem here so to be complicated
but what is the intuitive idea behind
this theorem well let us think intuitive
ly as to why the initial state does not
matter when the chain has a single
recurrent class and no periodic States
the technique is pretty classical they
use the following think about two
independent copies of that Markov chain
starting at two different initial
conditions so for example think about a
red copy and the red copy would
initially start at state two and then
will at each unit of time well join two
next States according to the transition
probabilities of this Markov chain so
for example so this is at time zero it
was here time one it might come here
time two
three four five and so and so forth so
this is one copy of the Markov chain
so think about an average up either blue
copy and assume that the blue copy
started here at time 0 and again in a
penalty of the other but during the same
unit of time it will jump from from
state to state according to the
transition probabilities again so you
know think that maybe this one will go
here then will go here so time 2 3 will
be here 4 here maybe 5 here and so and
so forth now look at these two
independent copies they were bhur time
and in that case for our little example
here is the time for where for the first
time they collide in in a sense that
they they jump to the same state at the
same time so a time for both of them are
here now think a little bit about the
future evolution of these two
independent copies given that they are
in state four now and here we are using
the Markov property to say that the
future evolution of the blue copy is
independent of the previous path given
that you're in state four the fact that
you studied in one does not matter for
the future evolution of that blue copy
and for the red copy given that you're
in for the fact that you started in two
does not matter to characterize the
future evolutions of that red copy
so in some sense probabilistically
speaking these two copies cannot be
distinguished for their future
evolutions
given that they are both at state four
so this means that the initial
conditions for these two copies given
that these two copies met at a given
state at a given time publicity speaking
nothing can differentiate them in the
future because of the Markov property
that's essentially the high-level idea
of this proof now the key thing here
mathematically is to prove that whenever
you have a Markov chain that has a
single recurrent class and this racing
recurrent class is not periodic and you
start from any
initial conditions the two copies will
eventually meet in a given state at a
given time with Priority One okay so now
let's assume that the theorem holds that
means that yes indeed we have proved the
existence of these steady-state
probabilities the questions is now how
to calculate them well the way to do it
is to start from our key recursion that
we had for the end state transition
probabilities so where we assume here
that we have M States and we are going
to take the limit on both sides of this
equality so when n goes to infinity we
know that our G of n will go to pi of J
and here when n goes to infinity in some
sense n minus 1 also goes to infinity
and so our I K of n minus 1 should go to
PI of K and so we are using that
property and again we take the limit as
n goes to infinity and we say that RI G
of n converges to here now the limit on
this side you have a limit of a finite
sum you can exchange the summation and
the limit and so you take the limit
inside the limit of our Aiki of n minus
1 when n goes to infinity goes to PI of
K and then you have the resulting term
and so from that taking limit again as
then goes to infinity on both side you
end up with this equation here for J now
you can do that for any of the J of your
markov chain so you have m state so you
end up having m equations and you have n
unknowns right the M PI J's so this is a
system of M equations with a men nodes
unfortunately this system is singular
and has multiple solutions and one way
to see that is the solution PI J equals
0 for all J is a valid solution to this
system 0 equals 0 so clearly this is not
very informative so maybe we need one
more condition to get a uniquely
solvable system of linear equations it
turns out that the system of equations
has a unique solution if you impose an
additional condition which is pretty
natural which is means that the PI J's
are actually probabilities they should
all sum to one in other words in the
future if you ask yourself what is the
voucher being staged a and and you get
PI of G the summation of all the
possible states have to be 1 if you
consider that additional equation Plus
that system here so if you consider this
extended system then you can show that
this has a unique solution and this
unique solution cannot be this one and
so in conclusion we can find the steady
state probabilities of the Markov chain
by just solving these linear equations
which should be numerically a
straightforward procedure